certains en franchi le pas à la grande
satisfaction des autorités les voilà
ouvriers encore un moment et les
syndicats auront remplacé les tribus
c'est un pays qui a été vert et peuplé
il y a à peine quelques milliers
d'années comme en témoigne ses girafes
gravé par les hommes d'alors
aujourd'hui ne reste que du sable des
étendues caillouteuses parcourus par
quelques hautains Touareg jamais mis en
valeur sur quelques plans que ce soit
[Musique]
c'est sublime étendues appartiennent au
Niger
dans la France sud du pays la capitale
Niamey est plus des 9 dixièmes de sa
population des noirs
plus au nord c'est le désert le pays des
Touaregs capitale Agadez
[Musique]
Agadez
mystérieux qui se voilent mais laisse
voir le visage de leurs femmes qui
portent encore tout sur leur chameau les
paix et la lance qui ne sont jamais là
que de passage vers les zones moins
arides du Sud où ils échangent le sel du
désert contre du mille
qui ont toujours refusé la
sédentarisation et la scolarisation le
Niger n'a pas eu la même chance que
l'Algérie l'Arabie le Koweït son désert
ne recouvre qu'une nappe de pétrole
[Applaudissements]
mais dès 1958 géologue et prospecteurs
du commissariat français à l'énergie
atomique laissez pressentir que les
plaines désertiques bordant la lyre
cette montagne qui se dresse au sud du
yoga pourrait bien cacher des gisements
d'uranium
[Musique]
alors après une prospection générale en
avion les équipes se multiplient et
parcourent le pays
[Musique]
qu'il y a de l'uranium c'est désormais
certain les compteurs géèrent le disent
mais existe-t-il des gisements assez
riches pour être exploitables
encadrille le pays systématiquement par
des forages pour connaître exactement
l'état du sous-sol
de l'eau injectée en permanence remonte
à la surface les débris du terrain
attaqués par l'outil au bout de la tige
il suffit de prélever cette boue
régulièrement pour suivre les
différentes couches du terrain traversé
mais cet ouvrier a également une autre
mission il doit pour le compte du CEA
qu'il emploie chronométrez les éventuels
arrêts de la machine afin que la société
de forage ne facture pas une minute de
trop
business is business même en plein
désert
[Musique]
240 mètres 240 mètres et vous allez
aller jusqu'à quelle profondeur jusqu'à
450 mètres ça va prendre combien de
temps ça va
pour deux jours je suppose que dans une
heure ils aient fini leur trou ils vont
se coucher ou pas
sans perdre de temps dans les 5 minutes
et nous déménageons à 10 km d'ici
puisque les trous sont à 10
km même si c'est en pleine nuit vous
allez repartir
[Musique]
au petit matin les équipes s'étaient
succédées mais rien n'avait changé
la machine creusait les hommes la
servaient un spécialiste apprécié la
composition du terrain
un peu effaré nous regardions ses
aventuriers modernes quelques Sisyphes
égarés qui jouaient au rendement et à la
rentabilité au centre du désert
pourtant ce fut par un matin semblable
que vint la récompense les petites
sables contenaient deux pour mille
d'uranium
c'était à 200 km au nord d'Agadez
dans un pays couvert de gros graviers et
six plats sur des centaines de
kilomètres carrés qu'il semble avoir été
terrassé par des géants dans une région
si déshérité que même les Touareg les
vitesses
qui était allé se cacher le métal de
l'avenir
oui alors comme partout il y a une nappe
il y a des nappes
en territoire désertique et entre autres
ici la nappe dans lequel on va exploiter
le gisements à un niveau pièceométrique
et lors de 27 mètres niveau auquel nous
sommes actuellement c'est-à-dire que non
seulement vous êtes en plein désert mais
en plus vous allez travailler dans l'eau
en plein dans l'eau il faudra pomper
tout le temps ah bah il faut pomper de
aux pompes depuis un mois il faut la
pomper jusqu'à la fin de la carrière
pour exploiter cette uranium il fallait
commencer par enlever 37 mètres
d'épaisseur de terrain il fallait
construire une usine et une ville au
bout du monde
rien de tout cela n'a rebuté les hommes
à partir de 71 la somme à here produira
750 tonnes d'uranium et à partir de 74
1500 tonnes
à deux pour 1000 cela obligera à
manipuler 750 000 tonnes de minerais
chaque année
[Musique]
les normes quantité de terre enlevées de
la carrière a été bien entendu déposé à
côté et dessine maintenant dans la plate
immensité la silhouette insolite d'une
montagne visible de loin
[Musique]
l'usine qui semble à peine commencé et
qui pourtant produira ses premiers
grammes d'uranium dès la fin de 1970
[Applaudissements]
enfin la ville
en 68 il n'y avait rien d'autre que
disons qu'un camp provisoire ou des
quelque chose qui se trouvait au nord de
cette de site où vous étiez ici et qui
en fin 67 au moment moi-même je suis
arrivé au Niger comportait 5 ou 6
garçons
et par la suite dans la cité de chantier
où nous sommes ici actuellement cette
cité de chantier a été constituée en
partie comme vous le voyez de cabine
climatisé très confortable d'ailleurs
nous avons vécu pendant un certain
nombre d'années
celle en célibataire et maintenant peu
d'année finalement puisque deux ans la
ville est né deux ans pour les plus
anciens quelques mois pour d'autres et
par la suite nous avons concurrent avec
des travaux
qui se réalise actuellement et
poursuivre en zone industrielle et bien
créer une ville
dans la zone de la société créer une
ville ça veut dire notre vie c'est une
c'est évidemment d'abord les logements
pour accueillir des familles et c'est
ensuite les équipements collectifs c'est
ça tel que dispensaire tel que l'école
tel que Club
un club indispensaire des logements de
l'électricité de l'eau mélangez le tout
agité vous aurez une ville
une ville tout le monde ici dit la ville
sans doute pour égayer d'autorité ces
quelques alignements de maison basse que
les architectes ont au milieu des tendus
immenses serrer les unes contre les
autres comme en banlieue parisienne
psychologiquement ses meilleurs
paraît-il
un jour il y aura quelques arbres on a
déjà engagé un pépinieriste
pour l'eau et bien évidemment la zone
d'Arly c'était une zone particulièrement
hostile
où il n'y avait même pas depuis touareg
et Touareg d'ailleurs
fréquentait pas cette région mais nous
avons trouvé de l'eau parce que de l'eau
il y en a il y en a plusieurs
profondeurs il y a trois nappes
notamment
une nappe qui se trouve où on trouve de
l'eau vers 40 mètres une note un peu
plus bas vers 200 m et une troisième en
Suisse à 400 mètres ce qu'il y a de plus
difficile pour l'instant c'est le
problème du transport des
marchandises qui arrivent du matériel
qui arrive à Arly étant donné que nous
sommes quand même ici au coeur du désert
c'est à dire à 2000 km
pratiquement de toute côte aussi bien
de Cotonou que d'Afrique noire
actuellement notre âge maintenant le
matériel se passe en suivant les
matériels part des ports européens
des parcs à Cotonou Cotonou ensuite
empreinte
d'âge même faire de Cotonou à Parakou
sur 400 km
ensuite il y a une rupture des charges
ils ont pris en charge par des flottes
de camions Société nationale de
transport nigériens qui sur 700 km de
pistes et bien les amène à Arly dans des
conditions pas toujours très favorables
parce que la piste n'est pas toujours
très bonne
saison des pluies sinon des pluies parce
qu'il pleut quand même dans ce pays le
beau coup il y a une pluriométrie très
faible qui est de 30 à 60 80 mm mais
deux ou trois jours alors ça nous fait
souvent un véritable black
les pistes désert du Nord d'Agadez sont
donc devenus la route de l'uranium
mais derrière les camions des
techniciens d'autres convois se sont
vite mis en route vers Arlit
ceux des chômeurs et des petits
commerçants noirs attirés par les
emplois ou par l'argent que les
techniciens ne manqueraient pas de
dépenser
ménageant le dessin d'une rue ouverte
sur le désert des paillotes se sont
annonces les formant ce que les
autorités d'Arlit appellent la ville
induite ici chaque soir à la lueur de
quelques lampes tempêtes et sans prendre
la vie des urbanistes l'Afrique noire
présente son spectacle
c'est l'heure où les chômeurs cessent de
se demander pourquoi ils ont abandonné
leur savane pour ce désert l'heure où on
oublie qu'après la dernière paillote
là-bas à 20 mètres il n'y a plus rien
rien pendant des centaines de kilomètres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir là le Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique reçoit en entrepreneur dans sa
petite voisine artificielle de madawella
les directeurs de la Somaïr sont venus
d'Arlit avec leurs épouses ainsi que le
sous-préfet tandis que l'on prépare
l'inévitable mais délicieux méchoui
amadawella le CEA fait la démonstration
de ce que pourrait être ce pays si
l'homme était si rare
[Musique]
des arbres verts poussent au centre d'un
plateau absolument désertique
il suffisait de creuser à ses profonds
alors
pourquoi ne pas forer partout
parce que c'est nabdos ne sont pas
réalimentés
ce sont des nappes fossiles
emprisonnez-la qui s'épuiserait si on
les exploitait abusivement
peu de pluie à retenir pas de mère à
dessaler ce n'est pas demain que ce pays
verdira
[Musique]
ces deux enfants dont les parents
travaillent au CEA auront peut-être 10
ans 20 ans peut-être plus sans avoir
jamais vu d'autres perspectives que
celles de ces 10 maisons
Touareg
[Musique]
merci Louette continue encore de donner
un sens au désert mais leur univers est
touché
la civilisation technicienne attire
toujours même les plus fiers des nomades
[Musique]
il laisse certains de leur puissance
sablée puisque de l'eau il y en a là où
se déverse le trop-plein des piscines
du bas dans la solide petite école
sous-tente ou le CEA forme quelques
prospecteurs africains l'un des cinq
élèves est un jeune Touareg
duo c'est-à-dire celle qui me traduit de
0 à 150 des chercheurs d'uranium dans un
pays où la scolarisation est
pratiquement nulle
l'histoire a de curieux raccourcis
[Applaudissements]
un détail nous a paru caractéristique
lorsqu'on assoit dans une Land Rover un
Touareg qui connaît chaque grain de
sable du désert il se perd immédiatement
ça va trop vite dit-il habitué au
lambalancement du dromadaire
certains en franchi le pas à la grande
satisfaction des autorités les voilà
ouvriers encore un moment et les
syndicats ont remplacé les tribus
peut-être faut-il s'en réjouir sans
doute même la manœuvre nous disait je
gagne 10 000 francs CFA par mois
c'est-à-dire 200 de nos francs c'est
beaucoup oui c'est beaucoup
mais je vous le disais bien qu'il
restait peu de temps pour aller voir
Agadez
[Musique]